what's up beautiful babies welcome to
another episode of get close i am bart
and i am the buddha
you wish i was a buddha i've never been
a buddha my whole life really doesn't
buddha just mean [ __ ] like a mean [ __ ]
yeah that's how you have to
just stick to your own language you
[ __ ]
okay
no stick to like say the words you know
and don't start saying other [ __ ]
especially when you don't know what
you're saying oh wait wait that that's
what i'm i mean speak english what the
[ __ ] we're supposed to understand each
other fine i said i said i fine i will
and i won't do that anymore
i only knew boo
boo
boo i'm like he's saying he's not gonna
do something yeah something no something
yeah yeah yeah
so in this podcast i did want to talk
about um
something kind of sad that happened
recently
and if you guys followed
um our vlogs
uh gio did mention it a little bit
but i think uh like elaborating on it
would be pretty cool
especially since i read the comments and
so many other parents have experienced
it it was actually really comforting for
me to read the comments
because like sometimes when like the
craziest [ __ ] happens you feel alone
you know and then so
for those of you guys who don't know
what i'm talking about um just a few
weeks ago taika had his second
seizure
and
it was really really scary now you're
thinking it might even be a third right
yeah yeah but we're not sure yeah so um
what ended up happening was um
for the month of july we were staying at
grandma's house because taka doesn't
have school so we thought it would just
be the cuniest thing to stay at
grandma's house so that taika could play
with his cousins both the ones that are
exactly his age so the three musketeers
and also
his two older cousins and just with
grandma there like everything just feels
so warm and cuny and nurturing
and
since the first seizure
which we did all the scans right like ct
scan mri
eeg all that like
the results came out what like not
inconclusive so there was no like
scare or not real scare i mean it was a
scare for sure but it wasn't like okay
the evidence is pointing towards he has
some sort of condition
and at that time we thought okay cool
it's just one
seizure
and they say for kids they could be like
up to two right like they'll give them
two before they really really i thought
it was like up to two no okay just one
so kids can have one
and then it'll be um which i think is
already wild right that the doctor's
like we give them one seizure before we
start like really looking into
medication and all that stuff yeah well
when i read into it seizures
it's just kind of like a misfiring of
the brain yeah so it can be as scary as
what we've seen or it could literally
just be like a
and we're back right that could be
considered seizure too yeah
so yeah so we were having a really cuny
time um was it like a saturday or
something
so um the first seizure he had that we
were aware of
was back in january
and um
that one was nuts because
we don't have history of seizures in our
family that i know of at least that you
know of yeah
so it was like a regular weekday
get a phone call from his school and i'm
always thinking it's like covet related
because at that time like every time a
kid was sick or taika even had a slight
cough or whatever they're like hey you
need to pick him up and i'm like ah and
i remember like i was having a meeting
with you and our other partner aaron
about like barbell and stuff and i'm
like oh man i gotta take this you
probably want me to pick tech up from
school he might be coughing or something
so i'm like oh and i remember like
rolling my eyes because i'm like [ __ ]
man everything is so particular right
now so i'm like hello and they're like
yeah uh is this tyka's mom and i'm like
yep and then they're like he had a
seizure i'm like holy [ __ ] so we rushed
to a school right that was the first one
i remember when you picked up the phone
and you're like what
and i was next to you and i'm always
just expecting like covert protocol and
so i was just like whoa that's like a
crazy expression and then uh yeah i
walked into your office and then i told
you yeah and then you're like taika had
a seat and i i remember like my
my my like my skin went cold my blood
went cold my hands it's crazy that you
feel so many things because for me it
was just like
so surreal
that i just i even be going what
and everything else is a blur yeah like
my hands went cold
it was just like holy [ __ ] like
that was something i was not expecting
to hear at all you know and i was just
like let's [ __ ] go i don't give a
[ __ ]
what's going on at the time yeah we
didn't speak at all we just left yeah we
got in the comments [ __ ] went yeah we
went we'd pick them up right or we're
like we we did that whole thing then
this time around and this is the crazy
part i'll explain in a bit but uh this
time around it's july
week and we had gone to train at barbell
brigade gym
um and it was in the morning so we got
back like maybe not like 9 30 10 o'clock
and uh it was me you grandma living room
and this is my perspective
and you have to fill in it on your side
because i wasn't there
so then i was really sweaty because it
was like a
hit type of like it was a high intensity
interval training day
or a metcon or some [ __ ] right so i was
super drenched and i remember we were
gonna go to the oc fair and i was
looking forward to the oc fair because
i'm like yes i get to take tyka to do
some fun [ __ ] today yeah pet some
animals yeah some rides i love fairs
yeah so i'm like cool we're gonna get to
eat
while we're on a diet but i'm like cool
i'm gonna get to buy him some dope food
to eat
funnel cake i've been doing a lot of
that watching corn dogs i make my mom
and tyka eat like some bomb [ __ ] and i'm
just sitting there watching them going
like is it everything that it's cracked
up to you and they're like oh yeah and
i'm like yes
anyway
so yeah i was looking forward to going
to the fair i'm gonna get ready so it
was
you sitting next to me here grandma
there i'm like all right fine i'm gonna
go finally i go get my clothes walking
into the bathroom as i'm walking into
the bathroom
i guess taika walked over to you and as
he's walking to you grandma says
something i don't know what it is but
she says something to him you already
start correcting his behavior like hey
grandma's talking to you
and then um i'm like oh man and usually
i chime in you know because i'm like
what the hell again taika because he has
his tendency of like not replying and i
really want him to acknowledge when
someone's speaking to him so then you're
like hey grandma's talking to you and he
likes to [ __ ] around so much so then i
was about to step in and i was about to
walk out but i'm like okay wait he
doesn't need [ __ ] three parents in
the room
like bart's gonna handle this sick
so i go in water's running and my mom's
in my mom's house is an older house so
it's one of those that like the water
tank the heat the big ones have to get
heated up so it literally takes like
five minutes for that thing to [ __ ]
produce any type of
lukewarm water
so i'm like taking off my clothes and
stuff and i can and she has like a
little ass window
uh overlooking the neighbor's front yard
and uh it's an apartment complex so
there's like these three little boys
that are playing i think soccer and
they're kicking around the ball
so i'm just kind of waiting hearing them
laugh and just kind of like kick the
ball around and just do boy things and
just play right because they're like
maybe
nine seven six like they're young little
boys
so i'm in this i finally get in the
shower
i don't even wet my hair i'm just like
barely like putting soap on
oh
i'm putting the soap on and i just hear
these kids playing but then i also hear
additional voices
right and it just sounds like a
commotion and i'm just like okay maybe
they're getting in a fight or whatever
and through these all these voices i
hear geo
but like it's one of those where i'm
like
oh it sounds like geo right like someone
said something that sounds like my name
and then i hear it and it's getting
louder and louder geo geo call 911 geo
you have to come out here geo and i'm
like whoa what the [ __ ] so i'm like butt
ass naked dripping wet and my mom i
opened the door i'm like wait what
happened and she's like she's like call
9-1-1
call 9-1-1 she's like um taika is
choking that's what she said taika is
choking and i was like
what so i go out and i see you like i
walk out so the way my mom's house is
positioned is
it's the bathroom door is here
you walk in this like little ass hallway
because her house is wet like maybe
maybe like 800 square feet yeah it's
like tiny if that yeah there's a room to
my right another room directly in front
of me
this little ass so there's this hallway
and then this hallway think of like an l
and then i can kind of peer into
the living room and then the kitchen is
on my left and there's like a wall right
in front of like a closet right in front
of me
so i turn the corner
and i see you and i hear you going taika
taika and he's like limp
and i'm like
and my mom's just kind of there
and i'm looking at you
and i can't really process what's
happening because all i hear is call
9-1-1 right so i'm going like i'm trying
to attend like my mom wants to tend to
like my mom's side wants to tend to that
and like tell you move because you don't
know what you're doing let me take care
of it but i'm going holy [ __ ] 9-1-1 and
i look at my phone and i'm like what the
[ __ ] and i go oh [ __ ] 9-1-1 right and
i'm like here you're going taika taikan
i could see him and like his eyes are
like rolling back
and like he's just lifeless and i'm this
whole time thinking he cannot [ __ ]
breathe he has something lodged in like
you're all that's all you're saying like
i'm like holy [ __ ] he cannot breathe and
i'm trying to think like okay as soon as
this person
says something i'm going to give him
direction like address right away
address what's happening get here now i
don't want to talk about anything else
and then i'm trying to think of like
what the [ __ ] like i'm trying to make
sure you're doing like heimlich maneuver
because again i was told he's choking
so
operator hey uh my son is choking he
can't breathe four years old i give the
address uh i'm like get here how far
away are you guys and then i'm going put
like put him over like like start like
um giving him heimlich right so then you
start like i don't know if you started
at that point everything's kind of like
a blur a blur
but now that's happening
and like
i'm trying to hear this [ __ ] guy
who's super calm obviously right who's
too calm for me like i need him to also
meet my energy not in terms of panic but
at least in terms of audio because he's
used to this [ __ ] i'm sure
so he's saying something but the way i'm
hearing it is like i'm only going to do
like the [ __ ] peanuts gang mom or
parents or all i'm hearing is
like it's that
it's that chill you know and i'm
thinking [ __ ] i'm telling you my
kid can't breathe that's all you need to
know get here like that's all i was
gonna say
so i'm like try i'm like what i can't
hear you
and then um
he's he says something and like as i'm
trying to like
be
logical and [ __ ]
there with the operator i'm looking at
you and my son in my mind is choking
his windpipes are blocked he's dying
slowly dying in front of my eyes so as
i'm trying to listen to this dude and
reply like a [ __ ] human that i am
my animal side just can't take what i'm
witnessing and i just i don't know what
to do because i'm like this the phone
call is really important but my son is
also really important who's not
abandoned because you're you're taking
care of him but i can see him in my mind
slowly dying
and i don't know what to do i'm like so
torn that i just start
yelling i just go ah
[ __ ] and i'm like ah and i look at my
mom and she's frozen and i'd like start
thinking about her because my mom's a
very like
traumatized person
she's had a horrible
childhood
so like i'm trying to think of how she's
feeling and i'm going
[ __ ] my only son is dying in front of my
eyes but i need to direct these people
to come and take care of this guy while
i know my mom is getting further
traumatized and i'm going
oh [ __ ] like i didn't i wasn't saying
[ __ ] but i was going ah to kind of just
like like let the energy yeah like let
the energy go so that i can keep moving
forward with thinking you know
so then um
i i'm like how far we are that he can't
breathe how far away are they
and he says some [ __ ] and my mom's still
standing there you're like giving him
heimlich or whatever and i'm like bend
him over because again something's
lodged because that's what i was told
so i'm like you have to bend him over
more and i don't know anything about
[ __ ] the heimlich cpr any of that
[ __ ] but i'm just assuming lodged the
positioning the angling needs to be a
certain way so that [ __ ] can just like
if it does get
unlodged
um he can just it just comes right out
yeah right
so then i'm like okay fine i got the
[ __ ] energy out by yelling so i run
to the front because like we live in the
hood so like we have bars and locks
galore and [ __ ]
so i'm like by the time the police get
here or ambulance or whomever is going
to get here to save my [ __ ] choking
child's life
um
i need to make sure that there's quick
access you know so i'm like how far we
are there how far away are they i get
the keys i dash to the front and i
unlock the gate and then um i like i
can't find the right key because we have
[ __ ] my mom's house has locks galore
so she has like 40 different [ __ ]
keys that all look exactly the same and
especially in a moment of panic
you're not trying to sit there and
decipher which one of the two silver
[ __ ] keys it is
you know so i'm like trying to do it and
like i
i felt bad because like
my mom's like coming out trying to look
to see like kind of what the status of
things are and i was like open the gate
because i just needed things to move
fast yeah yeah and in retrospect i feel
bad
because of her you know like past and
stuff and i'm like oh i feel so bad
um
and then
yeah like you're you're like he's
bleeding now at some point
like there's blood on his face and i'm
like what the [ __ ] is happening i like i
thought he was like
um spitting up blood
yeah i didn't know what was happening
and i was just
directing you to like help him breathe
and you're like trying to give him the
heimlich and like tycho's looking at me
and his eyes are like
all rolling back and you can see him
like fighting for air
it was [ __ ] rough
um
i guess that was like the point
between like
me calling cops coming
what was it for you
what up guys this episode is brought to
you by manscape if you haven't heard
already it's smooth sack summer when
you're playing in the summer sun make
sure you're escaped from your pubes to
the bump and ain't that the truth that's
freaking hot as hell out here in vegas
and when i'm sweating my ass off and all
of my sweat goes down to my pubes like
when they're there it soaks it all up
and then it feels nasty and wet and then
i don't even want to talk about the
smell which is why i shave regularly so
it stays nice and cool down there and
there's not a bunch of hair that
collects all the sweat and creates a wet
spot down there and the manscape
performance package 4.0 has everything
you need to prepare that summer bod
inside this package you'll find a
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer
weed whacker ear and nose hair trimmer
which i do use because sometimes i'm
getting old and i got the old asian man
hairs popping out and they got their
crop preserver ball deer and pretty much
everything that you need to make sure
it's nice and fresh down there and i
love the la
and i love the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer
because it features a cutting edge
ceramic blade to reduce grooming
accidents so like i could just go ahead
and go in the shower and i can go rather
quickly and which is why it's so easy to
maintain my hygiene and not to mention
it's also waterproof so whether you're
doing at the beach the lake or in the
shower which is when i do it it's so
easy because you just shave in the
shower and all the hair goes right down
the drain and it's
perfect it's just part of my routine now
so easy to do not to mention it also
makes it look bigger and now that i'm
getting more lean everything just looks
way more streamlined and
i look presentable get 20 off your plus
free shipping with the code get close at
manscape.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping with the code get close at
manscape.com it's smooth sack summer
boys get on board or get left behind
so for me
it was
um yeah just a chill day came back from
the gym really excited to go to the oc
fair because we've been planning it for
it all week you bought tickets
a few days ago you know they were like
okay cool this is tyka summer like let's
really maximize and do really fun stuff
and so
um i was sitting there on the couch i
know you're about to go take a shower
and uh taika
comes to me
um from he was watching like his ipad
eating breakfast or something and then
or eating snacks and he comes to me and
then he lays over my lap how uh just
kind of like lays over like just you
know when he just like comes and kind of
hugs your leg or just hugs you as a
person
and literally the minute he lays over me
and hugs my leg grandma tells him
something
and uh tiger doesn't respond
and i go hey taika like grandma's
talking to you that's rude
and then he doesn't respond and i so i
thought he was like playing pretend
right so i want to let him know hey it's
not pretend time like i really like
these when he was lying on you
like what was he doing so when he was
lying on me he was kind of rocking back
and forth um but i thought he was in his
pretend mode like he was playing a
character or like
you didn't have like actual eyes on him
no because his head is down so i see the
his back and he does that to me all the
time he'll just come and just lay on me
right and he'll or he'll make an animal
noise or he doesn't like this is a very
like
regular occurrence so he comes he lays
on me he's just kind of rocking back and
forth and then i'm just like hey taika
like grandma's talking to you and then
uh your mom's like no no it's okay i'm
like no mom like like this is something
we're really trying to establish
especially he's gonna go to kindergarten
i don't want him like
thinking it's okay like when um
you know adults talk to you that you
don't respond with something so i'm like
taika
and he still didn't move and i really
thought this time he was like really
into character so i just pulled on his
ear a little bit to let him know like
hey like this is parenting time i'm not
playing with you right now still doesn't
move i'm okay you're gonna go to timeout
and usually he get he hates timeout
right yeah that's like his end of the
world and he's still laying there and
then i was like
okay tiger we're gonna go timeout so i
picked him up and when i picked him up
that's when i see his lips like all blue
and his eyes like this kind of like
rolling around and i'm like holy [ __ ]
like when
no is that what you really said because
you're not like a outwardly personal i
don't know i don't remember what i said
oh i see but when you pick up your kid
and he's normally a very fun energetic
guy and then when you pick them up and
they're lifeless it's like one of the
scariest things in the [ __ ] world
because you pick them up because even
when they're sleeping there's a
different like almost
like it's angelic it's restful yeah
there's like there's a different feel
this one was like lifeless and i'm like
oh my god
so the minute i saw his [ __ ] lips
blue
um his eyes rolling around
i had no idea
what it was i had no idea if he was
choking or anything like that i just
look at your mom and i go ma call 9-1-1
you know i go ma go tell no i said ma go
tell call 9-1-1
and then i immediately go i try to like
uh give him cpr because his lips are are
purple so i lay him on my um uh on my
leg
his jaw was closed shut and i'm like
[ __ ] i can't open it i'm trying to stick
my fingers in his mouth to see if i
could open his mouth i couldn't at this
point you're not even considering a
seizure i'm not even considering it i
just see like i'm just going based off
of my visual symptoms blue lips this guy
can't breathe yeah you know so i'm gonna
go
so he needs air right now
and then so i stick my hands through my
his teeth uh i can't really open them so
i'm like [ __ ] this the only other way i
know how to do cpr is to blow through
the nose so i blow through his nose and
i see us
like his um
chest open i'm like cool he's getting
air so like whatever was at a thousand
is now it brought down to 900. i keep
giving him air like that
i keep breathing air into him because
you know even though when you exhale
it's co2 but there's still a lot of
oxygen content you don't excel pure co2
you know
so i'm putting some oxygen into him and
i'm looking at him and he's still
[ __ ] lifeless like this and i'm like
oh my god what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
would i do what do i do and i'm like
attack attack attack on my wake up wake
up i was like hoping like i can get him
to come too or something like get him to
want to like wake up i don't know what
the [ __ ] going on
and then uh i was like oh [ __ ] is he
choking because your mom was like he's
choking he's choking and my mom gets
that because uh
her
[ __ ] 30 plus years of being
elementary school yes yeah like that's
the number one thing that she's seeing
yeah and you know seizures not even on
my forefront of my mind and uh he was
snacking like you said yes yeah yeah um
so he was like he's choking his
shoulders oh [ __ ] so i opened his mouth
um and i think that's where the blood
came from because he probably either bit
me or bit his own
uh tongue or cheek or something and i
was trying to open it and as soon as i
opened the mouth and i i searched uh i
scooped there's nothing in there as soon
as i scooped when i let go boom the the
mouth closed right away so i was like oh
[ __ ] and then i think that's when i
thought like
holy [ __ ] i think he's having a seizure
that's why he's so [ __ ] tense like
that
and then i think her mom in like the
her traumatized state that she was in
from before she couldn't get the phone
to work so she was like i i can't shut a
code yeah so i was like tell geo i was
like go [ __ ] tell geo was you because
that i was i don't know my intensity was
high and then uh so she runs to go tell
you you come out and i think and i was
like call 9-1-1 and that's when you call
9-1-1 because at least that's something
that i learned from any type of first
aid or like like tactical trauma
training is the minute you administer
your first aid you need to get someone
else on 9-1-1 asap so
for anyone out there who has ever in any
any of these situations because the
quicker you can get professionals to
come
the the
the chances of surviving anything is
high so you want to almost do it like
simultaneously so i was like call 9-1-1
and then so you call 9-1-1 and uh then i
hear you tell me give him the heimlich
from my perspective in the world of
[ __ ] chaos i thought it was because
they told you over
the phone so i bent them over i started
giving the heimlich over and over and
over and over again
and um
i know it sucks because when you give an
adult a heimlich maneuver you can
actually break their ribs if you're
doing it right you can actually break
the ribs because you're aiming for the
sternum push in and up in and up and it
gets that gag reflex going you know
and so i was just doing it over and over
and out [ __ ] i don't know how long i
was doing it for probably five minutes
straight because my arms are [ __ ]
pumped and i was [ __ ] sweating and
drenched like crazy balls i don't give a
[ __ ] my [ __ ] son we gotta give him
back how to get him back and then i hear
you say it's working it's working and i
was like oh [ __ ] so i would pick him
back up to look at his face and i would
see his kind of come to a little bit
um and then he would kind of like go
away so i put him back over not knowing
that he's probably just coming back from
or waking up from a seizure yeah not
that this is actually working yeah you
know but i just keep going keep going
keep going
and then man thank god like
i know the the stereotype is cops take
forever in the hood but i i could have
sworn like i think they came in like
under three minutes yeah which is
[ __ ] amazing um they [ __ ] came in
and i think tycho was slowly coming too
and um well
okay
you explain things like a guy and
explain things like a girl
really yeah cause like
yeah they came in in under three minutes
and [ __ ] i try not to cry because it's
so emotional i hate reliving this thing
but
um yeah they come in like running
like they were charging in and i was
just like really grateful to see that
sense of urgency from people that they
care
yeah because i'm just like
it's not their kid you know what i mean
like
like no one else's [ __ ] matters to you
more or like
your own [ __ ]
like doesn't matter more to other people
yeah it's a job to them it's a job but
he's our child to us yeah yeah so like
that's what i would have wanted
you know so when they came in and they
were like running i was like
like holy crap it felt really good you
know because i'm like holy [ __ ]
again because i was thinking he was
choking
you know
um
and like yeah he was slowly coming to
um and they were like asking questions
and like being really soft and kind and
stuff
and then the ambulance
um also came in and this is the part
that was kind of rough
and nothing to this person but like
[Laughter]
oh my god
but like the head paramedic that was
like doing all the assessments and like
really trying to determine what was
happening is he choking like it like
what the [ __ ] is happening he was like
running all his tests on taika
and then he starts talking to me
but this guy has this like he has a
he's stuttering he has a stutter yeah so
like
initially when i
like i'm not in the right state of mind
he's talking to me and there's a stutter
and i'm thinking holy [ __ ] is it really
bad you know and then as he's trying to
get his words out quicker and quicker
i'm like oh [ __ ] he has a stuttering
problem but it was just making my
anxiety even worse it was literally like
a comedy show because you know like you
know
in the order of events
cops always show up first no matter who
you call no matter who you need whether
you need a [ __ ] stray dog
or house is burning whatever cops always
show up first and the reason why that
comes first is they have to establish
that this is a safe environment first
that there's no criminal activity
because unfortunately in the hood as
well a lot of people like to play
fuckfuck games so they'll call for
something only when they
only for firefighters or even medical
profession
professionals to arrive in a straight up
like
shooting when they're actually saying oh
my baby drown but they just they they
know how to play games with the cops so
cops always have to come and establish
it's a safe environment paramedics come
in so they always get there they get the
situational report first the set rep
right so they get the situational report
they know what's going on then they
brief the then the paramedic comes and
he goes
what's going on and i'm like i heard
that i'm like
are you [ __ ] kidding me because we're
[ __ ] our
hearts are do do do do do do do do do do
do do do every second yeah i'm like i
was like dude [ __ ] put the [ __ ]
thing the the does tycho need the
[ __ ] thing does he need a [ __ ]
like do you need to [ __ ] do this
thing like do something does he need to
pew like clear like do the [ __ ] thing
because this video yeah because this
[ __ ] eyes are like this and
[ __ ] and this was [ __ ] over there
going like
what's going on oh my god
and and and like in any other profession
or whatever or just any other situation
i don't give a [ __ ] right like you do
you you like i it doesn't matter to me
right like that if someone has a
stuttering problem or whatever like i
don't care
right like i can deal with it like it's
it's not a thing yeah but you know my
uncle my uncle has one and he's a
dentist so does your cousin yeah um and
i don't care it doesn't bother me it
doesn't change anything
i mean it's just it is what it is you
know um but in like this moment when you
think your child is dying and every
second every millisecond is [ __ ]
precious especially when you think that
they're gasping for air and every
like every passing millisecond they're
losing their life that's what i was
thinking
like to have someone that has a stutter
feels like an eternity for them to get
their point across you know so like it's
like having a [ __ ] flight attendant
and you're feeling extreme turbulence
but this flight attendant just so
happens to have a condition where they
like
sweat profusely
um and
and like i don't know they look panicked
but they're just chilling yeah you know
it's like cool you can be in any other
one except for this one just because
it's
it was rough man um
but like
once like they got there i felt more at
ease and then i was
you know able to like kind of like step
back a bit and just be like oh [ __ ]
i think he had another seizure yeah it
was really cool
because the only cop experiences i know
since i was a criminal
is a very like rough exterior very stern
exterior so to see all these cops um
under the sheriff's department shout out
to the sheriff's department for all them
to
rush in
put taika on like sit him on the hood
okay come here buddy come here buddy hey
buddy so sweet like just really trying
to like see if you can gather some
consciousness hey buddy how old are you
all right what were you doing you know
like that kind of stuff and you can kind
of see like him go like
like and then and then he would like
kind of like cry and this made me feel
like so cuny because he would like look
around i think he just saw a lot of cops
and it's probably really intimidating
you know and he just starts crying and
he goes like
and then at the minute he saw her faces
like he felt better so he's okay cool
i'm safe i'm um
i'm i'm like with
familiar people and the part that makes
me the the most sad is um
when he was laying over me
i thought
that
he was being a bad kid and being
mischievous you know so like when i was
like taika i was like in a stern playing
the stern dad position
and um
it breaks my heart that at his
most helpless time i assumed the worst
of him
you know i assumed that he was not
listening disobeying
and uh not being a good boy
when he was literally probably just
already having a seizure over my lap
so that was the part that [ __ ] broke
my heart i'm like [ __ ] what kind of
shitty dad i am that um
that's what i
my jump to conclusion was until i
picked him up and had the reveal and i
was like oh my [ __ ] god something
happened like he wasn't not
listening you know yeah
or you're definitely not being a shitty
dad if you're trying to
make him make him a [ __ ]
a good citizen you know what i mean yeah
like he's gonna be part of this
community and like
you know we're trying to instill like
manners politeness all that yeah respect
and all of that stuff so
um yeah that was one of the things that
you were holding on to for a minute
i don't know if you're still holding on
to it
um
a little bit because like
so afterwards when um he was he came to
and he wasn't having a seizure anymore
but he also doesn't have any
recollection of what happened like he's
kind of in that like
like super like um it's like a reset and
he's like coming back yeah he's coming
back and he's just can't even talk yeah
he can't talk he's just like what's
going on
um
and then he got strapped in to the
gurney to be put into the ambulance and
then i asked the paramedic i was like
hey how many parents can go with the
ambulance and he goes on unfortunately
with our staff you only won
so
you went in with him and i think they
immediately started doing like blood
tests right to see if there's no no no
they just strapped them in and then like
um they did draw like blood off of his
toe like a little prick see where his
like sugar levels are or whatever just
doing whatever blood test they need to
do
and um
when they took off and they said oh
we're gonna go to sc county and i'm like
okay cool and uh i didn't want to get
lost at all so i asked every bit of
directions i was like which entrance
you know because i don't want to get
there and not see my son i want to be as
i know i have to be apart from my son
right now because you're in the
ambulance and you're going to run all
the red lights obviously i can't tell
behind you so i'm going to uh i'm gonna
try to minimize that gap so i want to
drive directly to where the [ __ ] the
emergency room is so that guy was really
cool it's this exit or whatever whatever
cool they take off the whole time i'm
driving i was just bawling why i just i
don't know i just felt so bad like um
that
my son who was
helpless
and i thought he was being bad
it's like imagine like well i mean he he
usually and it's not being bad but he
usually is a [ __ ]
line stepper yeah you know he tries to
really test the waters
i mean he's a scientist yeah you know he
likes to see what his boundaries are and
i think that's just him being a kid
you know that's what kids do but it's
like
we have to make sure that we're still
part of this community or we would just
let him run [ __ ] ramp it and then
he's not going to be able to [ __ ]
coexist with anyone yeah so it's not you
being a bad parent yeah and um but it
just feels like as if like
imagine like your kid's drowning like in
literal like water
and then you're like oh he's just
playing he's just playing and then this
[ __ ] drowns you know that's how
it felt like so i was like oh [ __ ] so
yeah you guys get taken to the ambulance
to the emergency room i'm just driving
i'm like
[ __ ] um
i need to get there as fast as i can
i parked the car um i'm literally like
having like rolling visualization you
know like an improv it's like as you're
in this scene you're like envisioning
the next scene i'm literally like
driving my body and my car but i'm
looking for the emergency sign so i'm
like three four five steps ahead so i
see where the emergency room entrance is
whatever i'm i don't want to be awake
because i don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on now my brain has told me it's a
seizure but no pro health professional
has told me what the [ __ ] it is i don't
know what the [ __ ] is going on
and uh
this is like the first time like really
like in the movies where like i see how
dads are like or parents are panicked or
they can just suck a doctor in the face
like i was like i i understand that
feeling now wow yeah i rush in there's
like some [ __ ] there's like a couple
in front of me at scd they have metal
detectors and [ __ ] like that
so the they're like they're just having
a [ __ ] conversation like well do i
have to put my purse in or can my purse
go on the side or like i'm like [ __ ]
but what did you say i mean i didn't say
anything i was just like
like that and then she went in okay and
i put my stuff in and i ran i sprinted
to the information part i'm like my son
just got him into the hospital right now
this is his name um and then so he he
was like he looked it up he goes oh they
didn't even uh like get a room for him
yet but i do see that we're on the
receiving end and then i think from his
standpoint he can see how like panicked
i was so he was i'm gonna come i'll let
you know when it's your time to get me
and i was like you're going to come get
me or i need to come check back because
because like i don't want it's different
anything i don't want the baton to get
lost in this relay you know and then he
goes um he's like just come check back
in like five minutes so i literally just
found a chair
that's right in front of his window
so that like i don't want to lose any
time and then
yeah and then the minute that guy
checked in
uh in the system he looks at me and he
goes
and i jump out of my chair i walk over
there and then he walks me to
wherever i saw you and tycho like in in
the emergency room
oh
yeah and then when i get there
um
you know i just i just
cry some more because i just all those
emotions of like me assuming the worst
of him came back but i was also so happy
at the same time that he seems safe
and there's a doctor and it's not just a
doctor
like almost like
man when you're like on super parent
mode i'm like looking at people's badges
i'm like okay you're a doctor that's
awesome [ __ ] what kind of
[ __ ] doctor oh neuroscience okay cool
you're your brain doctor good good good
good like you know like everyone else
get the [ __ ] away and you don't know
what the [ __ ] going on you know so i'm
like i'm like holding him caressing his
hair touching his face
and like the beautiful thing about taika
is like he could be in like the
shittiest um
shittiest situations
but the minute his consciousness comes
back he's just a ball of joy and
happiness and optimism but that's why i
think it's so
scary yeah cause that guy goes away yeah
oh man it's such a stark difference
yeah so when he was there and as soon as
he saw me he like smiles he's like papa
and i'm like oh
my my cuny son's back i'm just petting
him i just want to make him feel good
and i'm like holding his hand
and i'm like man i've only like we were
apart for like 20 minutes for the drive
but man it felt like an eternity
i just felt like i missed him so so so
so much you know yeah
i think um
probably like halfway through the
questioning
like when the guy was stuttering and
trying to get all that information and
like the cops were talking to tyka and
and all that i was just like oh [ __ ] i
think he had another seizure
and um um if they weren't like rushing
him out then i'm like okay we're still
okay
because now i'm gauging these sense of
emergency based on their reaction yeah
yeah yeah you know so if they're not
flying out or calling for [ __ ] an
airlift
then i'm like okay it's not that crazy
he's not choking
obviously right yeah
so like i started slowly calming down
and i wanted to stay really level-headed
because at that point i didn't know who
was all [ __ ] up i don't know if you
were [ __ ] up i knew my mom was gonna
be [ __ ] up
so like any questions i was just like
answering it and i was just on it you
know so i can let you
gather your thoughts my mom gets settled
a bit because she did not deserve
to experience any of this [ __ ] you know
i'm not saying that we deserved it but i
think we can handle it more than
you know someone in her position
uh at her age you know like older people
should be chilling they shouldn't have
to [ __ ] see this [ __ ] you know
um
so like yeah i was answering a bunch of
their questions and stuff and they ask
you the same [ __ ] over and over again to
the point and like i understand they
have to yeah they have to
cross-reference each other understand
but at the same time i'm like
[ __ ] [ __ ] man can we just can i
just write it down once and that's it
you know so i get it
so we get in the ambulance
just just to have their backs too it's
because um the more times you ask
someone
generally more memory gets recalled so
more stuff comes out so that's why they
want to ask like that's why every person
needs their own account you know yeah
because you could be like i already told
the [ __ ] cop but the paramedics like
i need to know and then you get admitted
into like the er room you know the er
nurse or the doctor i need to know right
and then so they have to do it and then
like it helps recall that memory too
yeah that's cool
but in the moment it's just like please
i just want to i just want to keep eyes
on myself yeah
so then now we're in the ambulance
and they're chill you know so i'm like
okay if you guys are chill i need to
chill like i need to meet this energy
because there's no point in me getting
riled up and staying rolled up if the
professionals aren't getting robbed
because at this point was he able to
he's out no no no like sleeping out yeah
yeah yeah like he was coming in and out
and he was crying because he's
uncomfortable and he wants to take like
when you're in the ambulance yeah you
can't just i can't just hold him yeah
just for safety yeah um he's strapped in
he's strapped you know and these and and
if you've ever been in a hospital like
none of the furniture is comfortable or
soft or welcoming or it's not luxurious
it's like
it's industry grade industry standard
tough cold it's made to work yeah so
like he's very uncomfortable and he
wants and he's like on the gurney yeah
and he's trying to get up so that he can
be where he's comfortable in my arms and
he can't so he's like crying and they're
monitoring his heart rate and then he's
like because it's such a it takes such a
toll on his body when he has a seizure
like he is just done and he's exhausted
and his eyes are rolling back and
they're like monitoring the heart rate
and at one point
the paramedic was like hey buddy you got
to stay awake okay stay up because i
don't know what they're i don't know if
they're going like after a certain heart
rate that's danger zone i don't know
um
but yeah he's out he's just out so then
like
you know again like i'm trying to match
their energy so then they just start
talking like casually like we talk about
vegas a little bit and just it's way
more calm
so then as soon as i get out into the er
and like we get off within like seconds
you're right next to us like it was like
you were
there i was on a [ __ ] mission
yeah the minute i parked my car
i [ __ ] sprinted
[ __ ] in my as fast as my crocs could
keep up i ran
i ran to the [ __ ] crocs
yeah i went through the [ __ ] the
metal detector and the [ __ ] ladies
like put a mask on i'm like [ __ ] i
don't give a [ __ ] about your goddamn bro
but but i had to put that on because
they have you know like our nevada life
is way different in california life i'm
like okay fine give me that if you're in
nevada you still have to work give me a
chill out give me whatever the [ __ ] i
put that [ __ ] on and then i was just
moving you know
yeah so yeah that felt good like you
being right next to us
so then yeah they put him on the
on the table yeah even when i came into
the room i was just checking everyone's
[ __ ] credentials i'm like okay okay
cool we got a [ __ ] neuroscience
person in here because then
uh
i know if it's like a seizure has to do
with the brain so i wanted like the
appropriate doctor otherwise
i've been in like enough medical
situations where i'm like oh this guy's
just here to kill time until the real
person's coming but i wanted someone to
help him immediately yeah yeah
but they were so
so nurturing and so caring and they're
very attentive it was [ __ ] awesome it
was awesome and i'm not used to that
type of experience
with a lot of hospitals that i've been
to especially county hospitals you know
they're usually like understaffed and
stuff so it's hard for them to provide
that level of care that's like that's
why like that's why sc county is
notorious for like oh you broke your arm
well you're going to be in the waiting
room for eight hours because the other
guy got a gunshot
you know so like that area is rough yeah
that's that's stereotypical and that's
the stories that you hear so it's really
cool for them to just like
admit them straight and i think they
even in the er they had their own
pediatrics department so yeah they do so
it was just like straight to like er for
kids that was it yeah it was it was
freaking awesome yeah it was just for
him
um so yeah by that point
um
whenever i feel
the room
is high intensity whether that's
negative emotion or positive emotion i
always try to be the neutral one
because for me i'm like why do i need to
add to this you know so if it's ultra
negative then i need to bring it back to
the positive so then that's when i get
really positive or if it's like
not if it's ultra positive i bring a
negative yeah but like then that's when
i can stay neutral like that's when i'm
like cool everyone's having a good time
that's when my introverted ass goes okay
finally i can rest and then i'll go sit
down and i'm like yes everyone's having
a dope time i'm a chill but like in this
situation everyone felt really intense
for me at least that i was just like
okay let me just stay level-headed let
me stay calm like i i don't know if you
felt me all [ __ ] up or anything but i
really not that i tried to but that's
just my
my default you know
um
to where i did see you crying and i was
surprised that like you started crying
more and before me you know where i'm
like the emotional one and like all this
[ __ ]
so like um
yeah i at that point i was like oh [ __ ]
he had another seizure
yeah usually i don't cry
and usually i don't panic in situations
yeah but this is your boy but this is my
boy and
um
i don't think i panicked i think i
actually like everything that i've known
either from boy scouts the marine corps
or whatever i think i applied to the t
uh without a skip of b you know it was
immediately picked them up blue lips i
know i have to do cpr oh [ __ ] mouth this
shot breathe air into his nose like yeah
uh it was just like boom boom boom boom
boom like everything that i ever learned
i applied it
it was all wrong
but um that's what i knew because then
later on we found out
uh through our doctor when
they have a seizure and it's also
because we didn't it wasn't confirmed
that he had a seizure but we we learned
that
if someone is having a seizure um you
technically don't need to administer cpr
they're not choking what you need to do
is put them on it's not an emergency
yeah it's not an emergency it might look
like one but it's technically not a
medical emergency you lay them on the
ground because you don't want them on
any surface where they can like shake
and fall off and further into themselves
you place them on the side so they don't
choke on their tongue or any fluids or
anything that's in their mouth put
something soft on their head so that
their head has something nice to rest on
and then you just kind of let them be
and then slowly talk to them so that
when they come to
they're entering into a more nurturing
world
um and then with tycho like even though
like when you're having a seizure
technically every single muscle is
tensed so even your diaphragm which
controls your breathing but even from
there we learned that um even if your
diaphragm is tense and there the the
patient might be
like hyperventilating
um they're getting short breaths but
this they are still getting enough
oxygen to last like 15 minutes so you
don't have to administer cpr or whatever
but when the seizure goes over five
minutes that's when it's like danger
zone and you really want to call 9-1-1
but if generally if the seizure is
between two to five minutes
they'll usually just uh
wait it out and they'll come to and it's
not a life or death situation so that is
the pr uh actual protocol that we
learned that we want to share with
everyone in case anyone ever experiences
it in their
in their kids or in adults or even just
out in the public out in public yeah
yeah seizures look different every time
um and then the severity
um
it also is determined on like what like
where the seizure is coming from in the
brain
so like some of the seizures might look
like if you're having a conversation
then they start just saying jibber
jabber that can be a seizure another one
is like the stereotypical one where like
they start shaking
um drool comes out like sometimes they
might
you know pee on themselves or whatever
there's that there's also like spacing
out like where
they just look off into like space
and nothing else is happening and
they're like not there that's a seizure
so it's usually different every single
time but i think you know knowing
what to do how to react
um
and like the proper steps to take so
that we don't call emergency and do all
that stuff um
is is like just being well equipped so
yeah i'm glad that you're sharing these
tips because that was one of the first
things i wanted to do because we were
staying with my mom and i know my mom's
history um and we don't come like i said
from a from a background of anyone
that's ever had
epilepsy or seizures or any of that even
like a concussion that went into that
like into some type of convulsion like
we've never done any of that
um so because we were staying with her
my brother lives you know
near her and he has kids and they play
together and sometimes they take taika
and they do families they're not family
stuff but they like take him to like an
amusement park or the movies or whatever
and we might not go
um i didn't want anything to happen
and then and them not be well prepared
so that same day you know um i wanted to
make sure that one we can be united
because it's such a traumatic thing that
happened that i just wanted to make sure
that we can at least end the night on a
positive note so i was like hey we
should all go to dinner kind of get out
of the house because that house for me
at least i'm a very feely
[ __ ] foofy person you know like i'm
very
energy in there yeah i'm like a very
energy person
so like i'm like i don't know if it's
going to be the best for us to come
right back to this you know like i
wanted the house to kind of just like
air itself out our energy to be
different
so i'm like hey um i want to take you
guys out to dinner but before we do that
i do want to conduct like a class
so i wanted to teach everyone
specifically my nieces and nephews who
are you know younger than 13 actually
younger than 11. i think the oldest one
might be 11 or just about to be 12.
i wanted them to also know what to do so
like i held a class so i'm like hey guys
um it's confirmed now tyga does get you
know it does in fact get seizures
what sets them off we do not know we're
gonna run tests again
um he is on medication he takes it in
the morning and in the night now until
we can conclude what's happening
things might change at that point but
for now this is the new reality he does
get them
i was telling them like it doesn't make
him different we're not gonna treat him
differently we're not gonna like
like shelter or baby or not play with
him because he has this this thing like
it's exactly the same taika you know we
play the exact same way the only
difference now is
um
if we do go swimming for whatever reason
or if we do go swimming or or we're out
in like water where he could possibly
drown we just want to keep an eye on him
because we don't know or we can't
predict when the next seizure will
happen
so we don't want to leave him
unsupervised but he's also four so why
would he ever be in any type of body of
water where he can drown so that's
obviously like a given another one is
like if we're riding bikes or if he has
to climb something really high
um specifically the bike we do want him
to wear a helmet
so if something does happen while he's
on the bike he and he has a seizure he's
not falling straight on his dome
um but i said uh this is you know when
you do see it this is what they might
look like and then what i explained to
you when i'm like it could be like
dozing off or just starting to drool or
jibber jabber
or the shaking
if any of these things happen do not
panic it's not an emergency he's just
going through a seizure i said exactly
the steps you said right like make sure
he's in a safe spot
don't put him on the couch because then
he could fall if he is
shaking
uh put him on the floor put a pillow
down set him on his side because he can
you know because you tend to drool there
if you lay on your back it will create
like a pool
um and you can start choking on that so
i'm like just lay him on his side
look at your watch or anything that has
time and and you know anything that's
past five minutes we have to call like
well i told the kids this i'm like um as
soon as you see that lay him on his side
tell an adult and i left it at that
because i just didn't want to make it
super complicated like hey look at your
watch five minutes calm like it's just
too many things so i'm like just lay him
on his side call one of us because
usually there's always an adult there
and then i'll just tell my mom and my
brother and stuff the steps that you
said like what are the next things that
we do
um anything more than five minutes is
scary danger zone but for the most part
this being his second
um it doesn't last more than like a few
seconds
so i think once i was able to conduct
the class with them everyone felt at
least from my perspective they all felt
like calm
you know we were able to have a nice
dinner and
and somehow i thought it was awesome you
held the class too because i think like
it took some
leadership ability to do that and a lot
of times like when when people are like
in a traumatic situation
um
you're kind of like so focused on
healing yourself that i think
establishing what protocol should be is
like the lasting on your mind and you
don't want to inconvenience other people
so i think the fact that you're even
like you know what we need to have a
class so that we can get everyone
comfortable in here and then now we all
know what we're dealing with and we
could deal with this as a team i thought
that was such a amazing move on your end
thank you well i just felt like it was
empowering right like i never want to
inconvenience anyone either
so like
what am i supposed to do like keep taika
locked up right yeah and like me knowing
that this
may and possibly will happen again we
don't know when we spend a lot of time
with family we want to be around family
a lot i think it's only fair to equip
them and empower them so that they don't
panic you know so that they're not put
in the state that we
just went through because it is very
traumatizing especially when you don't
understand what's happening
and you think it's it's a life-and-death
situation like that [ __ ] really [ __ ]
sticks with you it's like a little crack
in the mirror you know like you can't
you can't patch that back up like we
could barely talk about it right now
even though we know that it's a safe
thing like just us reliving it again
we're like [ __ ] choking up and
fighting back a ton of tears because it
was so traumatizing right because
like the idea of losing someone that you
love is
something that i don't wish on my worst
enemy you know
um that i just felt like
yeah let's empower everyone so that we
can all calmly navigate this together as
a unit and it only just made sense yeah
it was cool to get the to see the family
get involved
because like and you can see that
everyone's invested too because even
like the like the junior high cousin
like asking good questions and like like
what happens if if the seizure calls
past five minutes oh then we call them
you have to call that one
you know so it's like it was cool to see
like people not just taking it like one
way it was a two-way street like we're
having a conversation about it yeah like
what about this can we put them on this
you know and it was just like really
cool to see everyone like really
wanting to master the information not
just okay so we're gonna listen to a
lecture it was like i want to master
this i want to know what's yeah it was
really rad it was really rad the
perception the the the way everyone had
received it
um
and like yeah no one treats him
differently now i even explained to him
that like
excuse me that he has to take this
medicine because he does faint so i
can't really explain what a seizure is
to him but he now he has to take
medicine in the morning and at night
um and without hesitation because i
think i've we've both been able to like
explain like hey this is what happens
and now this is just life for us now
that like he just takes it and he's like
yeah i don't want to faint the
interesting part of it is he doesn't
recall any of it which is crazy compared
to the first time because at school he
remembered that one he just remembered
falling he remembered falling but this
one doesn't even remember like
running to me because we were like do
you remember you see did you see the
like all the police officers that was
there he goes oh the ones that you
donuts no he said he said he goes oh
were they coming to take me to jail oh
yeah yeah yeah
and then there was a doughnut yeah he
said they have donuts and we're like no
like there's you don't remember there's
like cop cars all over the place and he
goes no i don't remember yeah but as
soon as he comes through like as soon as
the taika
wires get reconnected
he is just a funny kid he's like the
firecracker funny witty little boy again
yeah and like i remember one of the
doctors she came in to just kind of
check on his status to see if he was
like fine
and she's like
i just wanted to and as as soon as she
was gonna say something he was like
he was like being all wild and like
lively again she's like oh he's great
[Laughter]
yeah but it was
damn it was such
i'd yeah i never
yeah i mean you just feel so helpless
like i
am like happy i went through it because
it really shows me what i'm made out of
it shows me what i can handle
and i'm like man i wish i would have
like been a little bit more like
focused you know like task at hand and
not like panicking the way that it did i
think you'd handle that i'm not like
thank you i'm not like beating myself up
but i'm just saying
like this is just data that i've
collected about myself that like how
else are you gonna collect this data
yeah right and i love collecting data
about like who i am what i'm made of
what i can withstand what i can't and
like just building myself up so like i'm
i'm happy i went through it and we went
through it together because it showed me
what we're all made of i'm really happy
i was there because that was also during
the period where i was bouncing back and
forth like crazy wild right because
while our family
our immediate family was in
l.a my dad was still in vegas yeah so
anytime i'm done with any like la stuff
i go back to make sure my dad's not
alone i come back back and forth a lot
so it could have easily been a day where
i was especially if it's the weekend it
could have easily been a day where i was
just back here with my dad
and then i would have heard it and like
not having been there you know it's i
think it's cool that we all went through
it so that now it feels like we're like
super prepared for if we were to have
another
yeah i feel super prepared and then like
you know my mom feels really bad because
she's like god like
i was so stupid like i couldn't call
9-1-1 like she's like on beating herself
i i felt bad too because i was yelling
at her as if like i was in boot camp you
know i was like call 9-1-1 yeah i mean
like i was telling screaming like i was
telling her and i'm telling you and i
and i think in a state of emergency
i think anything goes right because it's
like we're just all focused on the task
at hand trying to make that thing not an
emergency anymore and i was telling her
and i'm told you too i'm like
in an emergency
that's why it's an emergency where no
one is prepared or equipped if we were
equipped it wouldn't be an emergency
anymore it's literally something we is
out of our control we don't know how to
handle the situation
so all is fair and i had to like really
re-emphasize like we're not mad at you
like no one is disappointed at you no
one is disappointed at anything that
happened
no one did anything wrong like i don't
think
you know you
missed diagnosing and giving him cpr
even though we weren't supposed to uh
like we even checked in with a doctor
like was that bad and she's like well
you don't need to
but it's not bad like it's not gonna
really harm him but like moving forward
you don't need to do any of that and
that's how we discover that they are
getting oxygen but like
this misdiagnosis and how we did i'm
like
now we know you know like i think
things always happen and and we need to
decide like if it's
if we're gonna take that and and have it
empower us or have it weaken us right
and for me i refuse to ever have [ __ ]
weaken me i'm always like dope what data
can i take away from this and i'm like
i'm glad that this happened to us
because one it unified all of us two
like we get to share this on our
platform you know like we get to
give this information up because prior
to this i had never i've only seen one
person in my life have a seizure
and i didn't know this person it was at
work that it happened and i remember
they put like something in his mouth so
that he wouldn't like
choke or do some [ __ ] or like bite his
tongue or some [ __ ] but like that's
misinformation like you're not supposed
to put anything they can hurt themselves
exactly you know and like i just went
with that and i was thinking that's the
right thing to do like i had no idea
you know so like how many other people
have not experienced or dealt with
people that have epilepsy or have
seizures or whatever um and i'm not
saying tycho has epilepsy because we
don't know but he has seizures
um and i'm like this is this is kind of
sick like i get to now share this
information and further empower everyone
else that's listening like
dope what other better person to go
through it than us
what was cool is uh even like in the
vlog where you shared it um briefly i
was reading the comments and there's
a lot of parents out there that have uh
kids
that got seizures too so it was just
cool to see like that there was like a
little community out there yeah and then
a lot of people like nurturing each
other and just even seeing the people
within the commons bond with each other
um was really cool so like i think um
for us to be able to share it just like
normalizes it even more and i think one
thing that was cool too is uh just
finding out that there are there is a
chance where he can grow out of it which
would be awesome you know so he doesn't
have to take medication for life or
whatever it is
so yeah then the next steps would be to
get further testing to see yeah i'm
going to run all the tests all over
again and conclude it yeah see what is
going on and what's crazy is the whole
reason why i even thought this was the
third episode was um back when tycho was
like one or one and a half or something
remember there was one he was a baby
yeah we were working he was
formula fed for a little bit yeah and
then uh your mom calling us one time
saying tycho was choking and since we
weren't there we literally thought he
was choking yeah cause she she justified
it with like oh maybe there was too much
formula powder and it could have built
up and she always thinks every kid's
choking all the time because that's her
experience from school um but starting
from
a young age
i've never seen taika like tucker has
always been smart and kind of like
particular so if there's anything weird
that's chockable in his mouth
so i was like so when your mom even told
us he was choking and he had blue lips
she said yeah when her mom told me he
was choking i was like
i don't know if tycho would choke like
he's so particular about stuff like he
wouldn't get himself in a position to
even do that
and so now when i think back about that
i was like oh wow maybe i don't think he
was choking i think he might have
because it was not like uh
like your mom was feeding him in the
high chair in front of him so it's not
like he could have just crawled off to
the side and stuck a lego in his mouth
he was literally right in front of her
mom and then he choked right in front of
your mom right so i was like oh maybe it
wasn't even him choking
he could have had like a seizure
especially since he just had one
right in front of me yeah and then the
other crazy thing and i think i read
somewhere in the comments too but i
didn't get to uh fully connect with this
person or even like reach out but i want
to
um they were saying that they had a
seizure after every time they had a
fever not like the same day but like a
few days later and this happened both
times with taika
so the first time that i can't name the
one that you're talking about because
that was no one was ever really
witnessing it so and we don't know he
could have just been choking yeah um
but at least for the first one the week
prior to him having that seizure he did
have a fever oh that's true but the
fever didn't go to that danger zone of
like 103 104 105. um where that's when
they're like rushed them to the er
because they it can cause a seizure it
was literally like a week
the following week when he had the
seizure at school this time around
the week prior
he did have a seizure
a fever i'm sorry
thank you yeah he did have a fever but
it wasn't in that danger zone again like
it was just a manageable fever but yeah
a few days later he gets a seizure so
like um they mentioned that they had
that too so i'm like oh i gotta i gotta
research that and see if like there's
some correlation there
um because she was saying like yeah my
parents didn't want me to get on
medication so she did the more holistic
route and whoever she saw like really
helped her and like she has never had a
seizure ever since so i really want to
look into that and see what that's all
about because i don't want to have him
on medication if he doesn't have to be
on medication so i rather take
alternative routes i'm going to just get
multiple opinions is what i'm trying to
say yeah yeah yeah like i'll do the the
nero way like we're we are gonna get a
cat scan mri eeg do that whole thing all
over again he is gonna have to get
sedated unfortunately and he is gonna
hate it but like sorry dude
um and then the other one a little bit
more holistic route and see what
what we go with yeah
but that was uh
that was a day to remember man
it was that day i'll always remember
thank you for being a stud because you
did not panic a bit
i cried in the car after
like a [ __ ] a little [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ]
no i hope you don't feel bad i did feel
at that moment before getting into like
when [ __ ] hits the fan i think i'm
pretty level-headed and i'm pretty good
at like attending to emergencies and
stuff
but i did feel
like uh
a sense of helplessness
that i'm like man like as you know every
parent you're trying to provide the best
for your kid right i'm like as sick of a
house as this is as all the fun stuff
that we do at the community if he was
really choking that this ain't doing
[ __ ] i know i was like none of this [ __ ]
[ __ ] matters like all the [ __ ]
bumblebee helmets that he has i'm like
none of that [ __ ] matters so it really
motivated me to i'm like man i think i'm
either gonna like
take some emt courses or something just
so like if there are any kids on my
watch um i'll be able to at least
troubleshoot all the most basic [ __ ]
yeah um because also one like you know i
think i can't help it with like being
like the comedian brain that i have
when i was driving to the sc county
hospital
as i was bawling my eyes out i was like
man i literally have the [ __ ]
the most worthless profession in the
world i'm like i [ __ ] make people
laugh
online and i can't even save my kids
life
you know i was like what kind of [ __ ]
job is this because you know when [ __ ]
hits the fan of it jumbles up your brain
yeah i'm like i'm [ __ ]
like talking about would i rather [ __ ]
my mom or my dad on jk news that's what
i do for a living and my [ __ ] kid
almost died on my arms i'm like this is
the [ __ ] stupidest job in the world
it's [ __ ] worthless
because like you're the real priorities
get shown in your face you know and i'm
like damn
that's crazy yeah gotta do more family
[ __ ] together
gotta like really reprioritize like
that's like it it did shake up my [ __ ]
too where i'm like a lot of this
material [ __ ] not that we're even
materialistic even to begin with um we
like nice [ __ ] don't get me wrong i love
nice [ __ ] but
in that moment like you said none of
that [ __ ] [ __ ] matters so like burn
it to the [ __ ] ground just as
long as i have my family and my bonds
are good with everyone and like i have
my unit and my team
i'm unstoppable
i'll get that stuttering ass
[ __ ] out of here dude i know i
don't blame him like i wish him the best
but just not i'm like can you keep him
at the firehouse something that's like
i'm sure he's smart and got all the
skills he does but he passed it man if
you got some guy that's like because if
you have bedside manners dude yeah you
can't be someone got bullet holes and
[ __ ] you can't be like
so
what
what happened
i'm like
that was rough i'm a [ __ ]
okay all right well on that note thank
you guys so much for listening thank you
so much for always having our back we're
always going to keep it 100 we're always
going to [ __ ] keep you in the loop
you know what's going on we don't fake
[ __ ] we are who we are we're always
going to be like this thank you for
accepting us and taking us into your
hearts we're always going to just give
you our best thank you and we'll catch
you next week